my Palms get sweaty when I watch videos
of people climbing up cranes yeah or two
things first of all I can relate humans
are incredibly visual I mean more than
40 of the human brain has something to
do with vision visual navigation eye
movements visual perception color
perception when we see depth of field
that's not parallel to the ground it is
terrifying with good reason because you
know what's the universal force that we
all experience from the time we're born
is Gravity the first thing you learn is
that Things fall down not up it's like
the fundamental rule that we come into
world with day one even though the baby
is kind of flopping around like a potato
bug can't even hold its head up but if
they feel like they're being dropped
even the tiniest bit they will go
wide-eyed so there's a built-in
vestibulo ocular reflex so when you see
depth of field in the direction of the
gravitational pull you actually get a
little bit of activity in your
cerebellum and that area of the brain is
responsible for all the reflexes
associated with the falling reflex if
you've ever been to a tall bridge or a
dam and you go to the edge and you know
because your body and brain are
preparing for this immense fall